in anticipation of tonight's State of
the Union we wanted to get some voters
reviews of President Trump's first year
we spoke with five voters in the Orlando
area of Florida a key battleground state
they range in age from 21 to 70 years
old three voted for Donald Trump in the
2016 election two voted for Hillary
Clinton our conversation touched on a
range of issues including the economy
and immigration we also spoke about how
political and racial divisions are
impacting the country Angela with the
word of a word or a phrase the State of
the Union is excellent when it comes to
financial the economy our jobs are
improving in everything we need to work
a little on the social problems that
we're having you know in a word or a
phrase the State of the Union is superb
bold and beautiful so so I'm sure the
economy is getting better it seems but
the economy is not the only thing that
we have to look at when we're describing
the country as a whole racial tensions
are increasing among whites and blacks
health care is a crisis in this country
we bought the opioid crisis I don't
think ultimately as a whole the country
is doing any better than it was
president Trump appealed in his rallies
to to kind of regular America not the
fat cats do you think that's played out
in his policies let's say for example
with the tax cut absolutely yes all of
you agree I agree I think it is
currently that's the way it's looking
and that's the way it's going to be for
a couple of years but one thing you got
to remember is that these tax cuts in
ten years for the average person go away
and for businesses they stay so that you
know we're gonna have to wait and see
Daniel what could the president do to
take advantage of his opportunity at the
State of the Union what I think he could
do is um really dig into the fact that
the economy is doing so well and how
many jobs he's bringing back I think he
can capitalize on the fact that he's
putting more money in American people's
pockets and he'll win more people over
whether the president's contributing or
not he's talking about the economy
enough in a country where all of you
have identified that some parts of the
American fabric that are in danger I'm
not sure but I do think over time
people-people will see the light as soon
as they see a bigger paycheck it'll
start to make them you know rethink
things and I think that's good but I
don't think money necessarily makes
happiness like sure somebody's gonna end
up with more money in their paycheck
every month but at the same time when
you face such systemic oppression you
know in especially impoverished
communities I don't think the money is
going to offset that you know what could
the president do as a Trump voter to
improve it with in terms of race
relations what would you like to see him
do he just needs to be unifying his
language is a little bit divisive you
know just remind us that we're all
Americans you know we all share common
values we all want to see each other
succeed and feed off that I work on for
just one individual my wife is black she
has no problems with him there are a lot
of black Americans they're in favor of
Donald Trump because they see that when
the boat raises they'll be raised along
with it the thing I notice about him
he's unfiltered and he's real you know
that's what I like and I would like to
see him work on toning it down what
exactly should he tone down just some of
the verbage that he uses in his Twitter
account you know sometimes it is
cringe-worthy he should be a little bit
more presidential acting Daniel when the
president once said with the exception
of the late great Abraham Lincoln I can
be more presidential than any president
that has ever held the office you think
that's true you know I don't think
that's true now in the past I think he
was playing into the crowd when he said
that but I'd like to see him become more
presidential it's actually one of my
biggest qualms with him is that you know
at times he comes across as childish and
petty Larry what gives you hope in
America well I hope that we can come
together and not tear the country apart
what's important is we're all Americans
and we need to met we really do need to
make America great but we're never going
to do it as long as we're we've got
leadership who constantly tear down the
other side or or they degrade some other
people I just hope that someday
we can become one but I don't know if
that's possible but I hope it is he's
the president behaving in the way you
just described I know he's not he's not
acting that way and the sad part about
it is I think Donald Trump has an
excellent opportunity right here if he
would if he would you know get his
rhetoric under control and start
thinking about everybody else instead of
himself I think that he can make a big
difference mark if you were to finish
this sentence with a word or a phrase
America needs to be more accepting just
accept him
I accept Devi for even though she is a
rabid I'm not rabid but a liberal yeah
I'm fine with that because she's
entitled to the opinion and that's great
these two of them they hope young people
who look at the world and they they want
to change it for the better
that gives me hope we'll have more from
our focus group in the next hour the
voters will share their assessment of
the president's record on issues such as
immigration and national security what's
really interesting to hear everybody's
different
there was a nice civil conversation as
well yeah was there anybody in the group
John that's started feeling one way
about the president but then changed so
lots of them were there yeah yeah mark
in the blue shirt there in the middle
said he thought the president was a
clown when he first saw him and and he
over time started to think of it more
seriously voted for him and then has
felt more secure with his policy but
even Debbie the one who but what a vote
for Hillary Clinton is not likely to
vote for president Trump ever again said
to her fellow liberals we should have
taken him more seriously and we should
take him more seriously now they had all
gone through an evolution and they're
thinking everybody keeps saying from the
very beginning we wish he would act more
presidential but yet they still say he's
doing a good job well that's the
interesting thing teeing up for tonight
they all accept that the economy is
doing well but that is not enough even
for his most ardent supporters in that
group all right